when we imagine the difficulties
involved in a so-called bad childhood
we most readily think in terms of
children who are physically harmed
beaten underfed sexually abused or else
treated with active contempt
screamed at blamed put down mocked and
tormented
such harrowing images make it hard for
us to picture that there might be
another
in many ways more prevalent yet just as
damaging form of injury
to which children may be exposed in this
case
there is no physical violence there is
no taunting or shouting
it looks at first glance as if all must
be well
but that would be to miss the particular
kind of wound that can be inflicted
through what psychologists term
emotional neglect we're so used to
focusing on abuses that spring from
interventions
we forget those that can equally
painfully flow from absence
the emotionally neglected child isn't
screamed at or hit
locked up or geared at they are just
often very subtly
ignored a parent doesn't smile at them
very much
there is never any time to take a look
at the drawing they just did
or the story they wrote no one remembers
their stuffed animal's name
no one notices that they are looking sad
and that the first day at school might
have been very difficult
there's always something more urgent to
do than spend time with them
perhaps another sibling to think about
or the demands of work
or of their partner there might be a lot
of parties as well
the parent seems in no way charmed or
interested
there are no cuddles or hair ruffles
there are no nicknames or terms of
endearment
birthdays get forgotten tears aren't
dried or consoled
the parent doesn't look the child in the
eye they might shortly after the birth
go off and live in another household
none of this may seem at first glance to
be especially bad
particularly because the insidious
behavior is largely invisible
it is compatible with all kinds of
outward signs of healthy family life
but that isn't to say that no damage is
being done
the psychologist william james
presciently observed that it might be as
bad
if not worse to be on the receiving end
of indifference
as of physical torment no more fiendish
punishment could be devised were such a
thing possible
than that one should be turned loose in
society and remain
absolutely unnoticed by all the members
thereof
if no one turned around when we entered
answered when we spoke
or minded what we did but if every
person we met
cut us dead and acted as if we were
non-existent things
a kind of rage and impotent despair
would before long well up in us
from which the cruelest bodily torture
would be a relief
a crucial fact of psychological life is
the disinclination of any child to think
that there is something wrong with its
parent
it will go to almost any length to
prevent the idea emerging
that its parent may be mentally unwell
or fundamentally brutish
it will remain attached and obsessed by
the most vicious and uncaring figure
whom an objective observer might see
through in an instant
the child will do anything rather than
entertain the idea that an injury has
been done to it by its own progenitor
especially if the parent is charming to
other people
and impressive in the professional
sphere the child would just assume that
there must be something deeply wrong
with itself
to justify the indifference it must have
failed in some way
it must in its essence be profoundly
ugly repulsive
deformed or lacking this is the only
conceivable explanation
for the blankness with which their
existence is received
the adult who emerges from such a
complicated veiled childhood
is likely to be in a confused state on
the surface they may experience
only good will and a continued desire to
please their early caregivers
but deep within themselves they may feel
lacerating doubt
paranoia and self-contempt to numb such
feelings
they may take to drink or develop
numbing calming addictions to keep
themselves from constant encounters
with their perceived repulsiveness
a measure of resolution comes when we
can take on board the term emotional
neglect
and treat it and thereby our own stories
with requisite seriousness
our childhood sorrows may not rank among
the most obvious or newsworthy
but they may be substantial and genuine
nevertheless
our levels of shame attest as much we
were not hit
but we were injured we failed to receive
the love that makes people firm
and whole that allows them to feel
authentic and deserving
that prevents them from being impressed
by those who mistreat them
and that stops them wanting to kill
themselves when they mess up
we hear so much about the virtues of
bravery
we miss out on the importance of
learning more regularly to feel
with appropriate cathartic intent
usefully sorry for ourselves
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected
areas of life click now to learn more
you